you want to do this you better be ready
to lay us the [ __ ] out and put us down
because we are going to keep coming and
coming and coming alright so moving on
to the controversy of the day which
actually stars your yours Truly's since
it's a little all of us here don't we
get that question of the day this is
something we've been running into her
coming by the way first off before even
the question we are coming to the
University of Illinois Urbana a lot of
people thought this was canceled the
live lot it was quite a broadcast like
you saw at SMU with the light show and
the sketches in the interactive stuff
that we had to cancel that but we are
descending upon University of Illinois
in Champaign / Urbana I don't know what
that means exactly doing it change my
mind broadcast live 7 on campus 8 p.m.
Eastern here in the Thursday show
question to you this isn't going to be
talking about today we've been running
into on campus and it's it's like
running into a brick wall consistently
and it's worse than the liberal bias by
that that's blatant we talk about the
CNN by omission have you run into this
what policies that have changed or or
rules that you feel or have seeing been
applied unequally I let us know because
that's what we've been running into with
SMU with Illinois so to start before we
get to SMU with Illinois the issue why
we had to cancel the the live show the
stage show again we're still doing the
change my mind was because there's a me
no security no security and we didn't
have access to the venue until two hours
before to even idea how many tens of
thousands of dollars in equipment do we
have to ensure that we send down it's
exactly it's pretty much it's a studio
that we have to bring on down well he
couldn't set foot on SMU without the
insurance right remember that well you
can't even come here with this stuff so
we weren't going to have access to the
venue and no security by the way and
there's a miscommunication with the
Illinois Republicans now they've the
show's back on they're letting people
know we're so glad to be working with
them and and have their support what
happened was they stopped we weren't
willing to pay I guess for the security
typically that's not how it works but
they're not coming anyway they said
there's no credible threat in case you
didn't know we have the FBI on speed
dial here at La Trobe so it doesn't
matter and now we've offered with a
change my mind to pay campus police
officers security full in cash up front
they're still not coming they're gonna
send one so it's an Illinois
you know Union state is there
an event with 652 thousand people
without any security just just by doing
that if you just do the actuary tables
there's someone's gonna die in that
crowd heart attack seizure or something
you gotta have security for any event
like that for any event none maybe we'll
send one guy it took all day to setup
down an SME there's no way you can set
up it easy
that's a nice 2500 and they were they
were awesome the most of people until
afterward they sort of booting people
some of the other members at SMU booted
the College Republicans who put on who
by the way fantastic thank you guys so
much for putting on that show that was
just incredibly difficult is up at just
the entrances and the exits all right
you know there's like 12 crazy they were
sending one guy in and you know that one
guy Vincent it's gonna be a Tim Kennedy
look-alike no you are asked to call your
son just to check anyway speaking of SMU
though we ran into this and this is
something that just we find very odd at
SMU we did have some protesters now SMU
was so grateful this this McFarland
auditorium was full the last one was
full was a Conan O'Brien der in the team
cocoa tour and not a no coverage at all
from the mainstream media but there was
there was tons of coverage on protesters
the protest was the Dallas voice I think
I don't know there was a bunch of
publication her to pick it up and there
were about 40 of them there first off I
think it was a clip from this girl on
YouTube let's make sure we give her the
credit because she went out and
conducted some interviews with these
these people had a problem with us at
SMU anybody want to talk about their
sign
my sign pacifically so so first off if
it's not her sign whose sign is it
these protesters who show up this is
what's kind of odd there's never an
event and Illinois without any police
present certainly when this is the
biggest event that night on campus at
SMU no one knows what their signs were
for no one had even seen the show I
wouldn't mind you know Crowder was like
Blake the last time he came here he was
in a space like over there by the
flagpole and it was a more general open
space that you know he would be able to
speak freely and stuff like that the
fact that he is basically what he is
saying is they all pretty much hate you
know I don't agree with that I don't
agree with he's getting this you know
this grand auditorium to be able to say
what he so you would just prefer him to
have a smaller space yeah I mean that's
so like smaller just a more general like
you know a place where like everyone can
talk you know just not such so grand
that's McFarland auditorium was just
there's this concept now that they just
I don't I would have been fine what to
change my mind they they kicked us out
at SMU only to change we had a permit
the group brought us in and they kicked
us out was that Sameer TCU do you see
you he see you that's right now we lost
that's right we lost the permit that's
mu they were they were fine actually so
sir I need to correct myself there so
there you go it was wrong I don't know
who sign this is I'm a dick it's not
that hard um I was finding it but I was
so mad that they gave him this
auditorium let's just don't have it they
may have a general concept of something
earned no did they give us 2,500 people
you did did a voice in Arthur once yes
therefore I would have been okay if if
this person didn't if they if more P if
less people wanted to see him then I
would be okay with it but because people
want to what that's what I
come out here and hold up a sign and I
don't know what I found it we walked up
with it there was 40 protestors max with
500 people an hour before the show lined
up down the block right that was the
thing by the way okay we're not we're
not showing up just to troll and get
people worked up when we show up we want
to do the show that's why it takes it
takes 15 people at least and a whole day
of prep to get this stuff going I think
that's actually the protesters if you
were just so deflated yeah they were
sitting there because everyone in the
line was like hey man could you good
good good for you you exercised that
First Amendment cool they were nicer
than the protesters realize everyone
everyone there was having a great time
and that was gonna happen at Illinois
it's the most fun party on campus
everyone's having a grand time they go
in there laughing they're cheering and
it's harder to show as opposed to a
lecture it's harder to show up and be
surrounded by laughing happy people and
protest without being like oh it's me
right I don't know maybe it's me and so
unfortunately what you know with
Illinois what's happened we've had to
we've had to scale this back because we
can't do a lot of with crowd or live
show going into it we can't do that but
we can do one hell of a change my mind
it's like in Fred Claus they just the
important thing is everyone has every
kid as a gift open on Christmas so it's
just baseball bats and who loops we can
change my mind we can set up a table and
a tarp and we're calling everyone out
there who's a mug club member if you're
watching this on youtube if you're
watching this on CR TV we want you to
bring your mugs come on out we'll have
some beverages I think we're gonna bring
we couldn't bring cigars it's a
smoke-free campus maybe we can maybe you
can chew on them we want you to come out
there and be our wall of security we're
gonna have some extra security but if
they're not only going to send one armed
officer because there's no credible
threat well we had six hundred plus
people reserved and we had another 500
people on a waiting list who knows who's
going to show up now when it's outside
we're calling on you to come on out to
University of Illinois Urbana and be our
wall of security and by the way and to
be kind we're calling on you to be civil
we want to create a path for people to
come up for the change my mind is going
to be a new topic today by the way
unveiled you'll be able to watch it here
live on YouTube live you want to know
how changed my mind unfolds you'll get
to see it for the first time live in
person so University of Illinois they
didn't have security they weren't gonna
let us get into the venue until two
hours before again they can say no sure
you're allowed or just not gonna allow
you to make a living no sure you're
allowed
we're just not gonna give you the
security
would give to anyone else just like
YouTube no sure you're allowed we're
just gonna hit you with copyright
violations that don't really exist that
aren't I'm cleared with any people
specified Twitter's there's no sure
you're allowed
but if aisle eights policies and this is
what the left does is is that about does
the law exist it's is the law applied
equally fairly and then in this case the
left as we see with University of
Illinois as we saw with some standards
at SMU again they were mostly great the
College Republicans fantastic we're
gonna do that dinner with you guys thank
you so much they not only don't obey the
law they create new policies that aren't
law and they don't follow their own
policies they don't even follow their
own rules that they put sometimes by the
way in flagrant disregard to the law
like Hermes Hermes over there at UT
Arlington ok by the way let's let's do
something here okay we're gonna do some
shows everyone here we know a lot of
credit live you want to do that that's
the full-on show sketches a lot of fun
that's what we want to do we're
entertainers but if you don't do that
we're gonna give you a couple other
options you can bring us to your school
we can do a change my mind or option
number three let's start with mr. Hermes
professor Hermes at UT Arlington who
went around spreading libelous memes I'm
calling you out you filthy son of a
[ __ ] I know you think that's cut that's
not it's not as bad as calling you a
Nazi mind you with fake names and
swastika zhonya you teach logic ok we'll
come on down to your school and we'll
debate you we'll start with you ok let's
start with this guy and then let's move
on down to campus again three options
ladders cried or live that's when we
want to do it changed my mind or take
your campus lineup all the social
studies gender studies sociology
philosophy I don't even know what these
topics humanities 101 professors line
them all up give us a list and we will
offer them the chance to debate I'm not
gonna debate obviously some nuclear
physicists on the third law of
thermodynamics but people who teach
philosophy people who teach sociology
people who believe there are 72 genders
and they're professors at your school
let's see if they're willing to step up
ladder with credible comment in town and
foot the bill and we will debate you
line them all up one by one just don't
line up anyone you expect back in one
piece intellectually by the way as it
deals with YouTube again University of
Illinois Urbana we're calling on you we
need your Thursday March 29th March 30th
March 30th University of Illinois Urbana
we're gonna do a change my mind segment
weighing 20 29 29 sorry I was on a roll
I was 29 we run away with the German
Pearl Harbor here's the thing we've been
it's been a rough because not only do we
deal with Twitter we filed a legal
petition of information with Twitter
Bill Richmond will be back we'll be
talking about that not only we've been
dealing with BS copyrights with YouTube
not only did we get booted we reserved
the space for an after party at SMU and
we have protesters there who show up
with signs that aren't theirs protesting
a show that they've never watched not
only were we not allowed access to the
venue is agreed upon and get an Illinois
to go in and simply bring in our
equipment and make sure the things were
safe not only do they not provide any
security but let's just be honest this
is a raw piping that conservatives
receive on a regular basis and here's
the deal we're not in there to be
predatory we want this we want this to
be the most fun show on campus okay we
want to come on campus visit you guys in
and make sure that this is the party
that college Republicans never got to
have it's a comedy show that's what we
intend to do we're not coming in for any
other reason we're not in this to be a
shark but you know what we can be I
talked about this that we can be one
hell of a pufferfish because if you keep
poking the bear we're gonna make you
wish you kick you you picked somebody
else okay if you're gonna come after us
with all this bold these bogus copyright
claims these [ __ ] OC violations not
provide any security and pull that last
minute and act as though it's on us
we're gonna make you rather wish that
you kissed a cement truck you can't stop
us we're coming to Illinois anyway I
don't know what we're going to do we
hope that you're there we are coming
non-stop on YouTube on Twitter on
Facebook there's nothing you can do to
stop us period ever period any other
thing if you want to pick a fight
there's going to be someone easier okay
that we're just going to make it
difficult for you and wish that you
picked somebody else so if you want to
do this you better be ready to lay our
stuff out and put us down because we are
going to keep coming and coming and
coming until there are no more mug club
members ever and the funds run out and
we're not able to come at you anymore
and believe me we're not the kind of
people that you want in your lives we'll
see you at Illinois this now is
different we're there we want to have
finally won this to be the biggest party
on campus but make no mistake we're do
want to change my mind it's civil but
this is now a take over it's a take over
at University of Illinois at Urbana it
starts now
did you like this video of course you
did let's there's something wrong with
you
in which case you can comment below
what's your problem with this video we
want to hear from you and we promise you
100% I give you my word as my bond will
answer every single negative comment for
those who are normal you can leave a
thumbs up and subscribe